eine woche schon ist die deutsche
touristengruppe in iran unterwegs
die pulsierende hauptstadt teheran
für die meisten der höhepunkt bevor es
wieder nach hause geht
museen stehen auf dem programm und der
große basar den kennen sie schon von
fotos aber das land die menschen selbst
zu erleben das ist etwas ganz anderes
total super die leute total höflich nett
zuvorkommend frage mich woher ich komme
bitten wir ungefragt kann also meine
nicht gemachten erwartungen wurden voll
übertroffen
zu hause erzählt marga dem iran das ist
erstmal riesiges erstaunen wie kann man
nur nachts in ihrer anfahren aber wenn
man hierher kommt man legt sofort
einfach sich in dieses leben rein also
es ist einfach ganz normal plötzlich
sicher zu bewegen
aber sie muss die islamischen
kleidungsvorschriften beachten und kann
das land nicht auf eigene faust bereisen
sondern nur in der gruppe die 15
millionen stadt teheran ist eine moderne
metropole nach dem ende der
internationalen isolation sehen viele
iraner im tourismus die große chance für
irland und manchmal auch eine
einkommensquelle für sich selbst
der iran hat viele junge gut
ausgebildete menschen aber auch eine
enorme arbeitslosigkeit reza danisch
mann hat arbeit im tourismus und sich
auf deutsche reisegruppen spezialisiert
er kennt deutschland und spricht die
sprache fließend
dieses jahr kamen mehr als 5 millionen
ausländische touristen in den iran ein
viertel mehr als im vorjahr bei den
tourismus so gut weitergeht bestimmt
gibt es gute chance für diejenigen
natürlich die in dieser branche arbeiten
wollen und ich kann mir vorstellen dass
nicht nur in der gastronomie sondern
auch bei den reisebüros als reiseleiter
und so weiter man gut arbeiten kann
das ist bestimmt für die
arbeitslosigkeit thema ein ganz ganz
wichtiger faktor das abzuschaffen oder
zu minimieren
dafür aber braucht es mehr hotels mit
westlichem standard der nachholbedarf
ist riesig
reza dann ist er muss auch mit
beschwerden klar kommen regelmäßig
bespricht er mit reiseleitern wo es noch
klemmt eine deutsche reisegruppe sieht
sich zum abschluss ihrer stadtrundfahrt
in gohlis tann verlasst im herzen von
teheran an
früher der offizielle regierungssitz des
schahs ist er heute ein museum
die deutschen fanden den iran sehenswert
und wollen ihren freunden das land als
reiseziel weiterempfehlen